Fox News has this report Boston's
Democratic mayor has come under Fire
after she sent out invitations for a
holiday party intended only for minority
City
councilors Michelle woo the city's first
Asian-American mayor recently had her
Aid Denise do Santos sent out an email
for the event email said honorable
members on behalf of Mayor Michelle woo
I cordially invite you you and a guest
to the electeds of color holiday part
party that's what the email said the
city leader quickly Drew criticism after
it became apparent apparent that the
email was sent to All City councilors
seven of whom are white the invitation
was meant only for the uh City's six
councilors of
color 15 minutes after the email was
sent out do Santos apologized and
clarified the invitation was only meant
for minority City councilors so just to
be clear she was not apologizing for
having a racially segregated holiday
party where whites were not invited she
was only apologizing for sending them
the invitation
the apology was oh sorry you you white
Devils weren't supposed to get that
apologies uh danda said I wanted to
apologize for my previous email
regarding a holiday party for tomorrow I
did send that to everyone by accident I
apologize if my email may have offended
or came across as so sorry for any conf
confusion this may have
caused now it's not that the the
invitation that's offensive it's it is
the party itself that is racially
segregated the Revelation about the
holiday party quickly received responses
from Boston city council outgoing City
councelor Frank Baker a white man called
the mayor's exclusion of certain members
unfortunate and
divisive citing recent tensions on the
city council Baker did not speculate
about the reasoning behind the mayor's
decision to host the party but said he
did not think it was a good
move um black City councilor Brian warl
held a different opinion and defended
the invitation suggesting the holiday
party was merely a way to represent all
kinds of special
groups
oh like that makes it better no no this
is just for special groups you don't
understand we we get to be at this
holiday party because we're special
because we're black and you're not so
that's all nothing to be upset
about
um five term B Boston City councelor
Michael McCormick said the party was not
typical of the mayor's office and said
former city leaders would have invited
the entire
chamber not just the black one
uh that was me that last part was my own
editorial okay so first of
all this is not the most outrageous
aspect here obviously but I I you know I
can't quite move past the phrase
electeds of
color you know that's the most offensive
thing about this to me even more than
the racism electeds of
color like what is nobody speaks like
that okay nobody nobody and this is
actually a good thing about leftist good
for us I mean bad for them but it's an
advantage that we have in U fighting
against these
people is that they're hamstrung by the
fact that they insist on speaking in
ways that no human being actually
speaks like I was just reading an
article on The Daily wire about a new
book about Hillary's failed campaign in
2016 and some of the Democrat insiders
interviewed by the for the book um
complained about this fact they said
that you know Democrat politicians like
Hillary they use phrases and words that
normal people never use and that's not
because the Democrats are so smart and
they're they have such a big vocabulary
and they're using big words that us
normal dumb people don't know no it's
that they they make up they invent their
own
language um essentially and and it's
intentionally
exclusionary which makes them sound out
of touch it's like it it's it's intended
to make them sound out of
touch which is fine I'm glad they're
doing that to themselves again it gives
us an advantage electeds of color I mean
can you imagine how bizarre that would
sound if some normal person in
conversation actually used that phrase
like if you were talking to a normal
person and they said yeah I was out at
the state capital yesterday and I saw
some electeds of color walk
by you'd say what what you saw
what what and by the way this is
something that for all of their flaws
Republicans don't actually really do
this you know they don't speak like like
Republicans will speak like normal now a
republican will use maybe a tone at a in
a
Cadence that sounds artificial and and
you know
politician but they don't use words that
nobody uses in real life they use
Simple uh normal everyday words like
there is no latinx equivalent on the
right okay like we're not making up
buzzwords and and phrases like that that
would never be uttered by a real human
and actual
conversation that's something that only
the left
does much to their
detriment this Christmas season don't
let the government be the Grinch of your
savings right now you can diversify your
savings with physical precious medals
while stockpiling free silver in your
home safe don't miss out on Birch gold
group's most popular special of the year
now through December 22nd for every
$5,000 you spend with Birch gold they'll
send you a 1 oce silver eagle coin for
free Tex Walsh to 9898 98 to claim your
eligibility now you can purchase gold
and silver and have it shipped directly
to your home or have Birch Gold's
precious metal specials help you convert
an existing Ira or 401K into a tax
sheltered Ira in gold for no money out
of pocket and they'll send you free
silver for every $5,000 you purchase
keep it for yourself or give something
with real value as a stocking stuffer
this year text the keyword Walsh to 9898
98 to claim your eligibility with an A+
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers now is the
best time to buy gold for Birch gold
Tech Walsh to 998 9898 and claim your
eligibility for free silver on
qualifying purchases before December
22nd that's a Walsh to 98
9898 but anyway um and this is also
something only the left does which is
racial
segregation and uh that's the real point
about this is the segregated holiday
party the no whites allowed
party and the real point with
that I think is the near total lack of
Justified outrage by the people who have
been discriminated
against like you've got one white guy
who calls it unfortunate and
divisive basically condemning it in the
weakest possible terms that he can this
is a government office holding a holiday
party where you are excluded because of
your
race and your only response is oh that's
unfortunate oh that's
unfortunate I don't know about that oh
GE G willikers I don't know
and and and you know yeah that's better
than the other siop fans who apparently
have no problem with it or are
pretending to have no problem with
it but you should be a lot more upset
about it than
that it's
divisive you know in these situations we
always say imagine if the roles were
reversed imagine it imagine just imagine
the the if the situation was reversed
and it's true that if the situ was
reversed there would be a volcanic
explosion of
outrage like you can't imagine if anyone
especially if any government office or
politician had a holiday party for
whites only okay like if if there was
some white mayor who sent out a holiday
party invitation to the city council and
said no it's just for the white ones
then send a follow-up apology sorry I
only meant to send that to the white the
white guys didn't mean didn't mean for
you for you blacks to get that
invitation this this part is not for you
I don't no it's okay it's no it's it's
cuz we're a special group that's why
don't you understand we're special
because we're
white okay that there would be a nuclear
like detonation of of
anger we cannot fathom the level of of
indignation there would be people self
ulating in the street over
this they'd be so there would be
Congressional hearings and FBI
investigations MSNBC anchors would be
weeping on
air they they'd be like RIT they'd be
like committing ritualistic Harry carry
or something on air in protest of of
this I mean you you can't even you
really you cannot whatever you imagine
would be the reaction it's it's it' be a
thousand times
that and then compare that to the
reaction in the reverse and the most you
get is one guy going that's unfortunate
H that's
unfortunate but we can complain about
the double standards all day it doesn't
matter the left isn't going to suddenly
decide to be consistent they aren't
going to hear what I'm saying right now
and say oh wow you know you yeah we are
being hypocritical I didn't realize
that good good point thanks for calling
us out on
that that's not going to happen so we
need to be the ones who respond
appropriately to things like this we
don't need to weep and set things on
fire the way the left does we don't need
to go and loot some random business that
has nothing to do with it the way that
they do but we need to be the ones who
are actually as angry and outraged as we
should be the mayor's office saying no
white people can come to my holiday
party is the kind of thing that deserves
outrage there's a lot of fake outrage
out there there's a lot of fox outrage
there's a lot of outrage over silly
ridiculous
things but this is not a silly or
ridiculous thing like the the mayor of a
major American
city saying this is this is not for
whites is is
outrageous and infuriating and that's
how we should respond to
it you can't wait for the left to
respond to it that way they're not going
to it needs to come from
us and we need to use terms not like
it's divisive or you know politics as
usual being divisive no that's not we
need to call it what this is anti-white
racism this is bigotry and this is not
Reverse Racism either this is just
racism just straight up racism against
white people and it is unacceptable and
and outrageous and this person you know
there should be an investigation into
this
person this how's this even
legal
um so we need to be the ones who react
that way we can't wait around for the
left to do it thanks for checking out
this video if you'd like to listen to my
full podcast on the go you can check out
the Matt wall show on Apple podcast
Spotify or wherever you get your podcast